New Game+ is he yelling it all right
start screaming there boy beat
I want you to do that again I'm reg a
New Game+ I guess I'm the boy I'm at
Reyes ha ha what's up guys I'm Eric
that's Rob it's early on a Monday
not everyone's by filled out the chat
yeah but you know it's all good we're
gonna check out a New Game+ not of war
cuz that's out and about and available
if you didn't know it illiterate I was
gonna read what it has a favor
I'm sorry that's alright well so we I'm
so eager you clearly beat the game cuz
now you can hit new game+ I should
probably move this picture picture in a
second see probably it's my is my guys
here but so should I hit New Game+ then
yeah let's do it
oh okay it picks from winning or saves
which say will it be Rob I'm pretty sure
this is the save a lot of buys bye bye
hi hi hi guys alright so new game+ we'll
start a new game with equipment XP hack
silver and purchased items from the this
guy this guy over right I got over right
no that makes sense you got to have
faith are you gonna do it or not well I
gotta over is are you gonna be a man or
a god I am a god of war where should I
put this I gotta I forget we're the best
place for the videos we'll find out in a
second
I think bottom right bottom is this a
new meme internet meme where everyone
says bye instead experience are you
gonna give me a check give me you got a
war don't that one's that one's rough
sledding I would say give me a challenge
more so than give me Oh actually case
let's go to the give me a challenge I
just want to see what the difference is
oh okay alright so power level 6-4 give
me a challenge I mean what should I do
challenge your balance it's up to you I
think challenge are balanced they're
both pretty good if you want to just
it's been a while since both of us have
played I know that for sure but so this
is the only one we don't do that one
this is the only one that you cannot
change it says mid-game so all I need to
start with challenge right I think
ideally I finished the game and then I
was like cool let me try this give me
God of War and I was like nope yeah so
here's the cool thing skip stuff so
let's skip this cheesy yeah but look at
you and your armor was that different
armor
oh you're right are you gonna chop the
tree oh so you really skip all that much
chop that wood right here right
angry scream you might want I get some
new subs on the fine how you doing
Daniel Cohen I'm waiting for your son to
show up something in just hype what's up
to everyone in one day happy Monday gout
gotta warn you game plus I think it out
for like an hour give or take the beauty
of it you can skip Cinemax if you're new
and haven't seen got a war we're gonna
try not to spoil too much but obviously
watched at your own discretion look at
you and your is that the yeah I think
that's the Moose behind one cuz I was
wearing yeah I was wearing me for oh
look at you and your cute little purples
oh hey man hey man I don't know I just
drive I didn't do I didn't do all the
batteries yeah so we're on Rob save
right now alright let's just skip all
this right yeah sure
it's fine we could get right into action
can we skip this - no - surname JR says
hi hi from Ireland hello we're getting a
worldwide audience thank you what does
it what it does and you game a mode okay
so there's a bunch of stuff let me list
it all out for you guys yeah let's hear
it because there's more than I can
I can explain here let me get the blog
up so I make sure that I get all the
right details correct oh you know what I
leaked it to you so let me pull that up
oh she probably wants this on Twitter
and it's probably to break everything
Oh even a trace has a cool little fit
yeah cuz you gave him a fit right I sure
did
boy stop it okay no you're good
pores I always gonna click the link I
got sidetracked Rob I'm so sorry here we
go
wish I could skip this is that say okay
that's fine
all right so relive you can relive the
story now except you get to keep all
your equipment you know your arm where
your talismans enchantments runic
attacks skills and yes even weapons New
Game+ is for everyone he's picked the
the difficulty as as we were able to
just now there's new customization
options with more powerful versions of
existing armors talismans and
enchantments you collect a new like
currency item called SCAP slag which is
used with our blacksmithing duo to
upgrade to higher rarity gaps lag yes
caps lag I don't know there's also a
handful of new armors that you can forge
for kratos anna traits including some
that have new gameplay abilities at
first this sounded really cool
when I read it and then I was like yeah
such as a chess piece which creates
massive explosions whenever whenever
health or rage stones are stomped on oh
and then I was like dang that's that
sounds cool but then like how often are
you actually stomping on like rage or
life stones yeah not that frequently
right cool I never really use rage all
that often I use it to get more life to
be honest right
personally it's like more whatever it's
fine um what else we have so you can
also convert certain talismans and armor
sets into yeah by converting certain
talismans and armor sets into
enchantments creating combinations which
are not possible in standard playthrough
enemies can now turn elite even on give
me a challenge plus difficulty add a new
dimension to combat even if you don't
want the ultimate challenge on give me
god of war some of the enemies have new
behaviors and attack patterns I can't
talk maybe you should see how you hold
up against those Valkyries the second
time around
I can't wait to fight the Queen again
alright so not be fun
so in essence because we have all the
abilities and like the dagger to get to
the Valkyrie we could do that but the
first time you see it right yes and then
cool that's pretty early I would imagine
you should be able to do that yeah
probably don't want to but good luck to
you yeah so test your skills on timed
realm tears running away won't help you
against Hell Vikings and revenant I hate
revenant
once you open a rift anymore you can
also receive a new shield skin when
starting a game on you game Plus and you
can unlock an additional one by
completing new game+ on gimme god of war
+ difficulty you can do the new game +
as many times as you want
as with most new game pluses you can
skip cinematics as we did earlier or you
can watch the scenes again to catch
secret - - I missed a enchantment that
was part of a story beat that was
actually a pretty good enchantment it
was like plus
something that all stats and I need to
get that sorry I'll get the chat in a
second sorry I'm just trying to read all
the things that are in there also
let's see so which are your Armour
pieces as much as you like without
worrying easily transfer all
enchantments from one piece of gear to
another in the menu with a push of a
button that's pretty sweet
alright and the last thing is there's a
mini bug this bug fixes and quality of
life improvements such as ensuring that
parry attacks keeps Kratos safe at all
times which is awesome love love to see
that and improving up the wrath of the
frost ancient rune attack that's one of
my go-to yeah that's pretty much most of
most of what's going on here all right
oh man it's been a while Eric I know I
would have - oh you're on no hug mode -
yeah you would you're such a badass
considering you're like kind of a quote
yeah bring that shield out oh wait you
cuz you don't have the prompts on either
huh oh you and your why
oh god dude I was trying to like yeah
angry acclimated I really am it's been a
while
that was a new move right Oh is he
you're dead I think you should turn the
hut on I think so through there's no
neato fees there's no neutral oh man
guys at the update I missed it I think
it's just a couple gigs did you do you
remember from when you were updating I
think is like two to three gigs are the
enemies more difficult at ng+ yes
clearly we're on just normal difficulty
and he pretty much died in a couple hits
so and he's got his fully decked armor
good what is it not showing so I just
doesn't only show up in combat is that
what happens okay so well find out I've
never played with no HUD so oh wait he
has no oh yeah that's right yep there we
go we're back
yeah he's frozen now give him the combos
still feels awesome okay so he's a level
six already
if you're curious this uh okay we're
already doing better much better
enemies are harder and they adapt to
your level yeah that makes sense
yeah give them the business yeah dude
I'm kind of stoked actually cuz like I
didn't really have a reason to come back
and I'm glad there's a you know cuz I
wasn't gonna start the story again
really look at that that took off
two-thirds of your life and that's
definitely a new move from that guy at
least that I've seen I haven't played
giving you got a war for too long so
dude I know you didn't ah wow it's been
a while Eric I know it's okay I'm gonna
have to probably dial it back on you can
do everything all over again and TG so
it's everything like the story and the
side stuff and all that stuff what
difficulty is this this is I'm gonna
dial back the difficulty I got it what
are you gonna do it gonna do the story
I'm gonna no I'm just one more back oh
you did give me a challenge is that what
you did ah yes okay so now you're gonna
go to the balanced one give me a
balanced experience that's fair let's do
that that's normal yeah okay so sorry I
think that back we were like on hard
mode essentially and now we're on normal
so yeah you keep everything in you gave
well that's interesting I mean spoil you
think you got spoiled I mean look I
tried to preface spoilers from the
beginning obviously if you haven't
played this is the four month
anniversary so sorry if you got spoiled
but I feel like 80 to 90% of chat should
be fine oh yeah give it yeah I wish they
added new executions that would mean
that would have been fun in itself
alright look I'm gonna try to monitor
the damage difference here now that
we're on normal set of hard Oh
also it appears that they could be one
less yeah yeah makes sense because give
me a challenge with level six monsters
now these are awful five monsters
instead yep
dude I don't remember any of my combos
anymore like no and I would be pressing
no alright now you're on normal it's
gonna be fine I'm sorry chat I'm so bad
we're officially out Nate it was out as
I think as of 10 a.m. Pacific so it's
been out for about an hour so now if you
want to you can totally that did way
less wow it did way less it did like a
fifth instead of two-thirds of your life
but he's also won one level lower two so
this is this is a balanced experience
very balanced yeah so yeah I'm uh I'm
definitely excited to get back into it
can't wait to fight the Valkyries again
I was all-in on dead cells now I'm
definitely gonna get back to this give
it to him
rip them up and inside your your your
bloodthirsty again I like it ooh get
over here
I'll come to you actually I haven't
actually watched enough that much stuff
off the Nvidia stream yet I'm curious
what cards they've revealed hopefully
there's another set of like pretty
reasonable priced cards because I think
the last 10 series that's 1060 1070 1080
were pretty reasonable sans the crypto
miners pricing yeah
we'll try a Pete it's been a while it's
been it's been a minute it's been a
minute we're we're catching back up do
you think there's anything different
with these like you getting it do you
think you get something cool we'll find
out you think I don't know I feel like
there should be at least something in
there right like maybe some hacks maybe
some of that new uh the new what you
might call it upgrade material maybe
yeah maybe one more where is it
uh I don't know the first one wasn't I
thought was all in the same room is it
yeah cuz I feel like the first one was
it was more of a gimme but maybe not
maybe I'm crazy $4.99 hahaha they
revealed twenty seventy twenty eighty
twenty atti nice when did they release
update sizes roughly two to three gigs
we're playing on essentially what it is
normal that wow the 2880 is only $4.99
that's pretty good maybe I should I'm
kind of glad I waited then to buy a new
graphics card because I was I need to
build a new PC same and if a twenty
eight he's only five hundred that's not
bad at all where are you going is the
new game plus the same like Witcher 3
where you choose a save game we chose
the save game yeah
oh wait the r-tx 2070 starts at 499
claims to be on par with the Titan XP
that's did you type that wrong crime did
you lie to me twenty eighty at five
hundred seems pretty insane Eric you can
pre-order now but it comes out the 20th
of September that's still not bad that's
in a month I wasn't planning on anything
I need that soon so perhaps I should do
that but then man do I go i9 seems kind
of overkill just not sure if I'm ready
to make like a almost two thousand
dollar investment all right well if you
guys see anything which link wise I'll
check out later but thank you
back to New Game+ got a war and thank
you for those tuning in from maybe just
coming off of the Nvidia stream it's
good to have you guys in here God of War
and you game plus mode is live for
anyone that owns it so come check it out
or go check it out or actually leave the
stream on and then also check it out on
the side that's what I want my advice
would be rip them open you know what
they should've did kind of is um maybe
well do good is like if they made it
where like executions dropped like
something like doom oh that one's good
too that's just off the heavy attack
hold right hold triangle or whatever
yeah yeah because that also creates like
a death animation god I love this one so
much I hate that one I think I don't
hate it I just hate it because you like
it I'm all about Rathod the frost giant
one freezes them it's good it's always
interesting to see how other people play
yeah cuz like there's so many ways
obviously cuz like I never really
perfected the whole like you know how
like you stagger your buttons and then
you get different moves you know I'm
talking about like behind RJ's like that
like what the colors up oh right well
then you do like different stuff right
yeah I like that's thing is I always
sometimes I just fall back into the same
[ __ ] for those of you
who don't know we're playing a new game
plus mode which carries over a save from
when you beat the game now if you
haven't played or beat the game yet
obviously there's gonna be some spoilers
so apologies if you're coming in now and
seeing spoilers but the game has also
been out for four months so you know now
so there's there's that new material
cool so who knows how many of those it
takes to upgrade something but we will
find out once we can find one of our
bros or one of our blacksmith Bros it'll
take some time to get there you know
speedrun no it's not that long till you
meet the first guy right Brock yeah
Brock I don't think it's he's that far
out that's for more about stuff I want a
ps5 since I work man yeah one day who
knows what are they saying like 2020
would be like a good time for that
because um it's like it's like the
anniversary for PlayStation all right do
Thank You Ryan for getting rid of that
guy who's being rude not just to me but
to also to rob which is stupid oh yeah
yeah he was telling us both to shut up
but with Rachel racial slurs oh great
anyways that guy can yeah forever wow
that's great kind of expensive Thomas
Sean the 2080 ti
1200 which is a 1080 TI it wasn't like a
1080 T I like about a thousand oh hello
yeah
oh is this the first giant guy he's so
interesting thing about this guy is I
got um I got like a different kill
animation than someone else
oh sure too different yeah yeah that was
one of those you yeah punch him in the
butt oh yeah you can d'être us now too
by the way
all right spam his arrows
charge of the white bear
it's back boy cuz he's a guy cuz he's
big and always nice dude yeah that went
well miles do this
give him the beatdown right in the the
streets right in the junk right in the
junk man I regret blinding gtx 1060 now
yeah it's unfortunate kind of
unfortunate timing i suppose by 1060 so
strong card god I'm like not playing
right Savio asking a question more
pertained to story and who we would like
to see as another Norse God I feel like
there's still a story to be finished
there still so I'm not sure who else we
would see and my endorsement ology is
not so great so forget to switch weapons
oh yeah
basically I always I went a heavy runic
attacks so I always just spammed my two
abilities and went to town on him that
on most of the bosses that way Adam yeah
go to sleep you gotta go sleep night
night night night baby
Oh nap snack God give that music boy a
[ __ ] blood now
you missed so many chests my man it's
okay I'm Charlie we're trying to trying
to get to get to some farther parts yeah
oh speaking of which as as to not have
to like pull you guys to different areas
try to explore and see not explore but
check out some of the new stuff check
out our man Balder here in a second
there are not any new trophies that I
know of oh yeah that's one I forgot a
down one that's a good one
don't mind me it's my phone you know oh
look it here's a Valkyrie right oh are
you gonna do it I dare you all right I
dare you you just don't find out if you
can do it in a second oh this is gonna
be good yeah that one so much there's an
item there get that hack silver I know
all right go fight a Valkyrie all right
cool drama dog dare do you call die
you're gonna die dude you have that
faith Wow I feel like I just came in
that's the same guy as the other guy hmm
well you can't do it he doesn't let you
so do you act maybe you have to go
through the actual story to do it yeah
that makes sense I would think that you
might not be strong well that's hard to
say
that's kind of that kind of seems a
little lame I would have liked to fight
them off the beginning
Wow I don't know I didn't it just did
not go well I messed that up again
man I am trying to pair you got a Magna
shield though that's pretty dope I've
never seen that before actually that a
thing your armor always did I'd never
seen it before
oh really yeah so that's a new ability
like I guess which we look into that
that's cool
please be respectful and chat I can't
stress that enough
we're trying to build a good strong
community here not a toxic one all right
it's easy Oh remember when you couldn't
fight them but now you can hello get
whips this is on balance difficulty
correct we were on challenge earlier but
we haven't played in a while so trying
to get react LeMay 'td to the game can
you can you burn that stuff now it's
behind you can you actually burn that
you should be able to write you with
your blade ship you know the blades do
that oh you argued oh look at that it
doesn't matter okay you have to go
through story yeah you do have to go
through the beats it's not or fully free
or maybe at least the tutorial stuff I
would say this is still tutorial you
know like until you get like Midgard
right oh yeah yeah find out I am curious
though to see if how open it is like how
much access do we have or do we actually
have to get through the progression to
get through the story beats and stuff
like that wait so they call this update
new game well it's new game plus mode is
what's being added so now you're able to
go through the game again the story all
those you know Valkyrie fights all the
sides side missions and things like that
with all of your equipment and on top of
that you know there's new armor to be
gotten wow this this guy like has no
life sorry and you're able to oh hi it's
the stranger and basically yeah you get
to play the game again except you know
quite some new not new enemies but
enemies with new abilities and then also
you know upgrade new upgrades he had as
well
do you think we would whoop him this
time like absolutely we whip him
oh you got realm ship - yeah that's a
good one yeah that's a good one
god I'm so bad this game right now I
figure you're overthinking it you just
got to become the God of War
yeah like that exactly give this man no
respect because he's not giving you
anything
are you even trying Rob yes
so cool I love the slow-mo in this game
I don't I never really use blades I
really hope we don't have to find all
the ciphers again the old sea-dog but
you know if we do oh good like I any
reason to come back and actually like
have a reason to like really play it
again is is enough for me because once I
beat it and got most of like all the
upgrades I could and beat the Valkyrie
Queen and stuff like that I didn't
really have a reason to play the game as
much but now with the new game plus mode
it'll just be like yeah I get to keep
all my stuff and then play it again
sounds like a fun time to me Josh John I
think we're just skipping through stuff
so if anything looks different we can
skip the cutscenes and that's only in
new game+ that other bed was for my wife
okay how'd it feel how does it feel
purple swag I had mentioned a lot of the
changes but it's new game plus mode and
basically yeah you know you get all your
stuff play the game again new armors new
upgrades enemies have some new moves
so Valkyries might be different so you
know it's tough to check out nice you
platinum do it so you're gonna try it
again yeah I don't think there's any new
trophies but um I think a lot of us as I
had mentioned just want to have a good
reason to go back to the game outside of
just playing on like maybe I gave me got
a war or something
because that was a little bit too much
for me I'm kind of a masochist but not
not that much so mr. Foote woz we're
just showing you guys new game plus mode
which allows us to you know play the
game again but with all of our equipment
already from our previous save as well
as you know all our upgrades and all
that stuff and also to tell you guys and
inform you guys that that new game plus
is available so if you want to check it
out go for it also because this is a
awesome game right yeah I did I love God
award I love this game
uh he has like a hybrid set of armor on
right now he has like the magma boulders
sorry it's a little loud oh you did that
I'll turn it down no you know you're
good it was quiet when they were talking
but I know I just I was in a me know
what's happening no worries
so yeah he's got a mixed set I've never
seen that magma shield before but I've
never used magmar where someone else
seemed to have seen it before
I've never seen it cuz I've never used
the magma armor I've only used the Nico
Heim armor would you guys give this go d
ask Aaron I mean that's really hard to
say we don't do a game of the year kind
of like voting and all that stuff until
end of the year also there's still a lot
of big games coming out this year but
this is one of my favorite games of this
year so far but for sure for sure so I
need oh definitely be in that discussion
but we're not there yet so don't want to
jump the gun obviously is a quick climb
Ranger
don't yes help me come to my fire I dare
you yeah get off me but come back come
back I can't make up my mind here
man what a difference this whole fight
is I know right like holy crap I think
just took me once or twice the first
time I can't remember I died it took a
while I remember I least read dead 2 is
coming out this year and TG 360 you know
there's also big games like Call of Duty
battlefield I know and maybe some
people's minds those aren't as big but
spider-man's spider-man as well as a
good shout that's in September
Raiders also yeah you got it you got it
keep going
you said battlefield who said Cod
there's not title 3 this year Jake I
don't mind if you hang out or want to
maybe tell people about someone else
streaming but you know be mindful of
that I suppose I get that some people
might be ahead of us but happy for the
people that are here to hang out to just
hang out
we're creating a rift in the world like
why would he tell us that it's such an
awkward thing to tell someone you're
like just like fighting I guess maybe
it's acting like a scare tactics like it
doesn't matter what you do to me I won't
be hurt
oh yeah smash brothers another big one
yep forgot that Ace Combat I thought was
this year but I think they always the
best player in the world okay that's
fair that's good to know
I'll check him out thank you for that
that was the other thing that was cool
that you know there there was some of
that I'm okay
I can do the sort of what you do auto
shower
this is like a glossy kind of cyborg
kind of actually but instead there's no
like come back next week as we find out
if Kratos and the stranger who will win
out of there
oh I lied you knew what do I know
maybe ooh all right I got it
Perry Perry just a last minute I haven't
really done any pay get rid of let's get
rid of that guy yes I feel like I've put
one guy in timeout like multiple times
and like literally
come on why would you trade this game in
ah that's a tough one Hey
I will say though not everyone has you
know just like crazy amounts of income
and you know they do want to play that
next game right and sometimes trading in
that game that you had played or we're
playing and getting maybe half the value
of the game helps you buy the next one
then you know that that's a thing right
but yeah oh he dodged it you know also
like I said there's I'm glad new game+
exists but I haven't I really I
personally haven't played got a war
since um when the first came out because
or like when I had gotten as far as I
did because there just wasn't anything
left other than trying to play on a
harder difficulty for me so like I said
this is a good excuse to get back into
the game and it's a nice way to
celebrate form the four-month
anniversary yes I love that movie so
much what is New Game+ as big yeah IG
basically you get to play the game all
over again except you don't lose any of
your progress your items your upgrades
all that stuff so now you get to you
know like I said a reason to get back
into the game and oh come on play it I
don't know
see you later oh my man I'm buying the
game again since New Game+ is that Wow
nice hello
all right we're going to UFC now rear
naked chokehold
this is legal in UFC this is totally
legal well not today you would have
tapped out see he's tapping out oh
you're right I'm talking about the move
after you beat the vowel queen there's
nothing else to do
yeah I mean like once you kind of finish
Muspelheim and also when you fit good
night when you finish knee fall high and
you finish the Valkyrie Queen there
really isn't much left to do sans like I
said playing it again from the beginning
on a different more difficult or higher
difficulty rather yeah and there's and
there's new armor as mentioned the
enemies may act slightly different which
is cool and there's a new upgrades for
armor as well so there's definitely a
good amount of reasons to come back if
you were curious kemell ebo says what do
you prefer that actually changed I
personally like the axe
I like the axe more I like the axe more
but the the blades are really good for
like crowd control you're like it's
really good at dealing with a lot of
stuff on the screen because they're just
big you know but when I want that single
target DPS or just like that weighty
weighty attack the axe is definitely my
bay that's pretty yeah all right man
just can't time people out long enough I
guess
oh I think I got that guy gone for good
goose that's true the high boy that's
true
Savio also saying he prefers the runic
attacks at least on the axe compared to
the chains um yeah I don't know I I
mixed him up a lot
I basically used I went a heavy runic
attack personally that was just how I
built my character so I was used I was
pretty much using runic attacks as much
as possible swapping between the two
we're pretty early into the game we're
still in the 1st we haven't even gone to
like mid guards and all that stuff speed
run all right cutscenes you can skip now
as well mm-hmm we're definitely not 2
seconds in the game maybe like maybe
like an hour is about right yeah we're
depending how you look at it cuz we have
sped through some of the cutscenes yeah
that's all I've been 40 minutes for it
so yes I'd say about an hour's about
right yeah we're about to hit an hour
are you gonna be able to take the boat
around gorgeous yeah we are in a ps4 Pro
but of course streaming at 1080 60
because we're play not gonna stream 4k
anytime soon I'll keep coming back yeah
you do that
Isaac or Isaac let me give you guys the
blog update to show you guys all the
different things that you guys can get
from playing new game plus we are just
on Normal difficulty Brendan as
mentioned earlier it's been a little bit
since we've played so just getting react
limited give me God of War is I think
enemy start a level seven and then give
me a challenge enemy start at level six
and they did way more damage I would say
in comparing normal versus hard if we're
just gonna use those terms a normal
attack was doing about a fifth to a
quarter of health whereas on hard it was
doing about two-thirds so I'm on the
hardest difficulty at the moment I'm
trying to get platinum in the game I
love it too much yeah that's awesome I
know some some folks that are going
through on gimme got a war and that's a
little much for me but it's definitely a
good challenge if you want to get
through that I think give me a challenge
just was pretty good though
kind of why to a private release around
2023 yeah who know it's probably gonna
be a while but I'd rather them take
their their time to you know really do
what they did here you know I mean I
guess you could say that but like also
you know they've maybe have changed
their formula right like that was that
was probably what took so long was like
oh so you think that now that they have
the foundation it is here for them to
make the next game I want to say I think
it's true I think they know what they're
doing now well that makes sense actually
cuz like what if what if they could time
it for like you know the inevitable
maybe ps5 release that seems perfect who
knows when that will come out again I
had mentioned maybe 2020 because like
that's like an anniversary for just like
the PlayStation but you know that would
be two years I don't know if that's
enough time though to be honest
mhm Brendon saying I heard give me you
got a war challenge or difficulty is not
as hard on you game plus as it was the
first time around it's possible just
because maybe you have the skillsets or
you have everything already Brendon
whereas if you play give me got a war
previously you'd have to start from the
beginning and have nothing so yeah it's
possible we haven't tried it though so
dad says I think difficulty shouldn't be
about bullets punching I wish it was
more about the tactics a AI enemy used I
mean the AI is definitely smarter and
different and gave me got a war but yeah
they are stronger and they get more life
I mean I know that that might not be the
best solution but you know even in
master mode in breath of the wild that's
kind of just how it is right like they
gain their life back they regen they
have more life they're hard to kill it's
just part of it right hmm what's up
catastrophic how are you doing they say
hello to me nu Rob
so Sid you guys need to do this with
anthem yeah I'm definitely looking
forward to playing anthem um I'm
cautiously optimistic hoping that you
know it'll be a good solid game as you
as some of you that come
tune in to games my live which we stream
every Monday to Friday at 11:00 a.m. no
I played a lot and still play destiny so
you know if there's another game that's
out there that you know can kind of
channel some of that but also give me
something new that'd be cool oh do you
have that one ability yeah I never
leveled that up for those like I don't
care about setting that stuff back it's
it's easy to like so like you know you
can just like forget about them
ossama monster says blend breath awhile
and the enemy types also appear in
master mode rather really there's new
enemy types in master mode it's
essentially like a level up or like you
see more like gold Lionel's so you see
more gold enemies so it's not like a
different enemies different class of
enemy okay so but that's not a new enemy
type though right it's the same enemy
types but they're also leveled up right
essentially or you seem like you said
frequency and difficulty well yeah I
haven't played master mode so I defer to
you guys on that do it i watch each
other blue phone no new enemies as crime
had mentioned
just that they some of the enemies will
have new moves is all the kind of a
statement that they made they said they
use the Valkyries as an example that you
know try your hand at them they'll be
you know different this time around
oh it's coming back isn't it a little
bit I don't remember there being this
many enemies or maybe it's it's been a
while since I've been in this area oh
yeah one shot I like it that's like the
other thing is just like how stylistic
you could be like how much you could
just swag on your enemies and now that I
get to swag on them for the beginning
again yeah I can't wait
Elden I didn't actually see the r-tx
announcement because we're also in two
meetings here at the office but I heard
I've heard some cool things love that
one I love how the heavy finisher I wish
more of the moves actually did that to
just some of the weightier attacks could
actually just do their own kind of
executions that weren't just like the
are three executions cuz that heavy
accent AK has a couple where you just
like chop the limbs off and stuff like
it is so good new anthem demo on the
23rd says bio oh really
23rd of August or September vile and
and/or playable I guess let me look that
up let's take a look
I don't know if that's an actual date
interesting
so for anthem they're gonna have that
one week lead up with early access so
we're probably have to play on PC or
Xbox one so that game we play on
probably PC I guess that's another
reason to get a PC new PC yeah I was
like if it's anything like destiny like
destiny feels personally for me better
on a PC than console like the field of
view and everything yeah game changer
you can't change the field of view in
usually you can't in most games on
console it's it's usually on PC that you
can change field of view no in Scott you
can all decide did you hear that games
like God of War will be going to PC I
didn't realize that no said Sony's
releasing the content to PC next year
really that's I am taking that with the
from one person's comment and I'm hoping
you're not rolling me that's pretty cool
if that's the case
you and your charge of the white pen
don't it's such a good one don't be some
pairing Rob I feel like you're warmed up
enough like that yep
maybe the windows shorter now
nailed it
okay maybe don't you do it when you're
ready
how about that I don't want to force it
upon you the way almost did you stop my
room I was worried that wasn't there
anyway
Mark Harmon says thanks for the stream
today makes me want to replay got a
worgen yeah mark definitely thanks for
tuning in of course thanks for the kind
words it's definitely like I said for
myself it's a good time to go to God of
War go back to God of War anyway now
that I've been incentive eyes with new
game plus mode and it's available for
anyone that has the game you know take
your save and enjoy it cuz man some of
this I just forgot how good this combat
was yeah you know you just in that
moment you're like oh yeah like when
you're playing it's like yeah it's
awesome amazing but after not playing it
for a while
it's crazy good times interesting do you
like the blue arrows cuz I've always
been about the stun oh I forgot I could
swish yeah and then I always had the
wool
oh yeah that's good
oh yeah throw the boulder you need
somehow stone perhaps there's some
LaMarcus Holloway as mentioned new game
plus mode you get to take your character
through all the progression you've done
and bring it through the story again you
know go through the side quests and then
Valkyrie fights all that stuff except
this time you have all your stuff and
you can upgrade even farther or further
further your armors further and then you
can also find some new armors there's
like new enchantments and stuff like
that too so yeah cash offices can't wait
to play more got a warrior yep looking
forward to it probably a place I'm at my
desk during lunch it's gonna be good
times I'm probably gonna be like robbed
when we first started and not know what
the hell I'm doing
yep and steal weird but warm and it's
gonna feel so right Fernando so far
actually bring up a good point there was
World War 3 gameplay that was showcased
today and it does it didn't remind me a
lot of battlefield yah oh yeah
even like the text a little bit with a
kick kills and stuff personally reminded
me a bit of outfield so paint that's
playable at Gamescom so that's pretty
cool I think she threw him off the ledge
I know I was trying to this guy does not
give a F about your attacks he's like
they tickle
the birds summary was by far the best
really you like the bird something come
on I was all about the wolves I always
whoa that was a glitch
I was always about the wolf stun because
I could always get in for sure I don't
know personal preference Oh
oh yeah that's right you can only parry
the yellow Hat's all right that's what I
was I'm so used to dead cells carry
everything or what I try to parry don't
always bury but because I think that's
it oh there it is he's back ladies and
gentlemen
Kratos the God of War send your friend
over here
hey you're afraid once to say hi oh come
on I shouldn't I should have kicked that
guy off oh good dodge spidey-sense the
birds look epic the birds did look epic
that's for sure I was
I will say about the birds the one
reason I never platinum got Awards
because I just didn't have it in me to
farm all the Odin Ravens maybe you all
with the punches you'll definitely get
it yep
oh wait didn't let me are you trying to
throw him off yeah that's a good move to
save time like on the Moose whoa home
trials inside for sure let's try to get
this house yeah there's more help in
that corner - yeah yeah I heard they
added new equipment and new game+ did
they really
yes Fernando we haven't found it yet cuz
we're I don't think we're far enough and
we haven't we haven't gotten to one of
the blacksmith's yet but they're
supposed to be new Armour they had
mentioned like one of the armor sets
does like a new move where when you kind
of crush or stomps health stones or rage
stones that it does big explosions no
idea what that looks like but curious oh
no I hate revenues by far number one
hated enemy type in the game oh it's
actually fun when you can get her in a
execute because which means punch em up
it's based on how much I hate I hate her
that I always want to try to execute
them I think the Night Elves have my
favorite death animation like they tried
oh yeah try to get away and they're like
yeah it's so good dude he Chuck's the
spear I don't yeah so just a white bear
you are done tortured white bear and
there's a new upgrade material which we
got one oh yeah we're I mean we're
getting close to Brock I want yeah you
old Brock Brock left right should I not
even go down there and just keep going I
don't know you do whatever your heart's
desire man hey
okay this is this is your Kratos okay
alright I'm just at Reyes city so you
know go like pull a chain down or
something for you
that'd be really cool blue cuff they
somehow added a secret boss but I am i
duh I don't know I mean I guess more
reason to go through the game right I'm
definitely gonna be playing again and
getting through it and doing all that
fun stuff so yup and then he hacks him
up I didn't do enough and - so you're
missing your head alright yeah that's
not good old Brock was there oh nice
there you go there's another one escapes
lag scamp / I guess you didn't get it to
perfect is the upgrade is what they say
so it would be cool if they added like a
boss run so good see I love that shield
that's like Captain America ask you know
calcium know what new bosses or enemies
that we know of they they definitely
didn't say if that was the case they
just said that there there's one right
there I don't think they're they just
said that they have some new move sets
is I mean let me get the right
terminology for you so some enemies have
new behaviors and attack patterns maybe
you should see how you hold up against
the Valkyries this time really is what
they wrote in their blog post this is a
LOF subject what does anyone have or try
the Infinity Gauntlet yeah I have it the
Infinity Gauntlet on my character no
sleep and it's pretty good I think that
the Infinity Gauntlet or the bat
talisman is actually one of the
potentially best talismans in the game
because it allows you to equip three of
the
like three enchantments and if you have
really really good enchantments it's
they're pretty insane I will say I'm sad
because I'm missing one of the best
enchantments or what I feel like is
potentially one of the best enchantments
of the game which is like one that's
tied to story that gives you like plus I
think 10 to all stats which is like
pretty insane I think it's 10 it might
be 7 10 seems kind of too good
Oh where'd you come from
it did indicate on on the screen I know
just saying just say post a look again
sure we can do that's totally fair
here's the blog post
Jeffrey Maga says why one complaint
about this game is that the execution
animations got repetitive any word if
you add any ones I don't see that I can
see it getting repetitive I kind of I
kind of got over it
again I do think the Dark Elves one is
like I like seeing that every single
time yeah
even if it is the same and I don't know
you start to mix it up you can kind of
do some of those other execution right
ask ones with the heavy attack yeah
heavy charge up yeah I don't know I I
can see it I can see why why he feels
that way but it didn't it didn't totally
bother me for whatever reason I don't
know maybe I'm a bloodthirsty man just
like killing people I mean cuz you can
make the same argument
um about doom right like doom like the
executions are really cool but some of
those kind of go can potentially get
repetitive but I never found them with
predators
there's no my rage is already filled not
even a big deal yeah you could have been
maxed it but it's fine I know I have
that one that Awards +7 we're doing all
of Rockford Sanders stuff Oh enchantment
I know for sure there's one that I
missed that has like plus two all stats
up oh that missed ho-ho have a boulder
you have a boulder everyone gets a
boulder everyone gets a boulder oh hi
did you across from the other side
did I I don't know I must have missed it
it could have been like a weird
perspective thing for me but that would
have been real badass if he did it I'll
have to watch that back on replay at
some point oh I am excited for doom
eternal personally can't wait
me too just give me some metal give me
my guns giving my upgrades just go to
town on some demons oh sorry for yelling
crap I am trying to die so I know
oh yeah rage if you need to use it okay
well thank you I never used a
resurrection stone because I was right
that's just it was a waste or to me was
a waste like I just felt like if I died
I wanted to go back and do a proper
myself and I don't know but that's me
just being me oh wow he gets so many
health stones
holy schnikeys Alex Cross wait a minute
new game+ what did I miss you didn't
miss much on you game plus basically
lets you just go through the game again
with all your upgrades and items so I
know that
thanks Karen
TSM croco says anyone excited for Spyro
or spider-man spider-man for sure for me
I don't know I've never been too much
personally into Spyro but happy that you
know the people that are we'll have
another go at it once it comes out hey
does my armor glow red when I have rage
ready look it's like I said I've never
used that armor side so I have no idea
I've only ever used an equal hime armor
set oh hello
normal humans you want to you guys are
all in big trouble too quick for you
what's up gaming with a zigu is your
shout out what's up man
or what's up cow
yes Daniel you can play it now if you
have got a ward you the update I want to
say it's roughly two to three gigs but
I'm not 100% sure but not not too big of
an update it is available though if you
want to play it so check it out going
there definitely too far there you go
come here
come on the on the backswing on the
backswing the updates out Alex go play
it if you want to it is available for
all who owns the game oh nice little
ribbon there oh you dare it was a trick
we got trick boy who's gonna pull the
chains now for us oh you should get that
little cutscene stop making out of this
guy you're okay you're okay
he wasn't gonna attack you it was
self-defense I was only eight hundred
megabytes all right my game was probably
behind then thanks Jeffrey why even try
attacking Kratos these people are out of
their hand well the thing is they
probably don't know that it's Kratos
what are you look at you
wrong weapon though although what do we
do do we just kill them with our bare
fists when they're when we didn't have
this yeah yeah yeah just got to go yeah
may I use your shield use your hands
where the character still Opie like
you're a character maybe Oh
on his knees he had to get pulled up
looks like they level up tooth they can
potentially level up in give me a
challenge I don't think they level up on
normal you can skip cutscenes now would
ya on you game plus you can skip yeah
there's a there's like GP captain it
seems like some of the the enemy AI will
be like like you know slightly smarter
or they'll have different attack
patterns and then like they specifically
called out try fighting the Valkyries
and then if you do give me a challenge
difficulty which we'll just say is hard
which is the third tier enemies can turn
now turn elite even on give me a
challenge which i think is that level up
right I think that's what that I think
that's what elite is but I'm not yeah I
was like where they like level up to
they're like next level
yeah thanks blue pup yeah there yeah as
don't Massachusetts oh they are higher
level mmm-hmm he's depressed now that
he's killed someone
pretty standard I would say yeah look at
you angry at these jars mm-hmm Hades
joke let's get the Brock boy let's go
what arm is that he's got like he's got
a combo of the Moose wilheim as well as
like something purple armor I called him
a peasant he's not in all gold he's not
gold tier Oh
I told him he could play my save oh okay
yeah we probably should just played your
safe it doesn't matter though it's not
like it's gonna make a huge difference
in my opinion and it was cool to see
that a shield of magma shield effect
that you have on your your armor that I
don't have or rather that I've never
used yep
nemesis Gonzales out today as of 10:00
a.m. if you have got a war if you're at
home go and play it if you're not
hanging out with me and Rob as you watch
until you can get home to download it as
a I think buffa and Jeffrey head said
it's about 866 and megabytes so not a
huge update come on some more upgrade
yeah we got three escapes lags three of
them whoa why are you oh oh one a 51/50
to go that's just for this area as a
total no yes no it's the whole thing hey
it's our boy Brock dang man why you
gotta hit him like that
who'd you like more bra curse injury
Sindri was uh they said that they've
made him the more based off of the guy
the character that plays monk right oh
yeah he's like a germaphobe and all that
stuff Adrian one what's the difference
here let me give you the blog post and
it is free as heck that is true
it is free
oh wow you just hundred percent of it
yesterday says Nemus that's awesome
now you can get back into it there's new
armor for sure infinite you can upgrade
your previous stuff farther I think
there's also I just gave you the blog
post of like all the things that they've
added yeah so you can upgrade more
powerful versions of your armor your
talismans here you go see level eight
cod of lot or is that new wow yeah that
looks pretty new it means it's using the
that's the one with the explosions yeah
alright screenshot that I need more
screenshot that you got it we need to
actually can I said I can just send that
I can send it I can send it okay you're
gonna that's fine if I go full game
I need more sketches send this to our
news team cuz that's pretty cool oops
hello it's it's like a teal medal I
don't know do look how big they are
are there are they're all is there like
a full set yeah oh yeah you know what
we'll just do it after damn you can be
the cod of war
woo I could probably get one of these
yeah no I mean either lapse lag dude
you're living that poverty life although
it's just you just started so it's not
easy
Oh tune is that different oh yeah okay
oh dress yeah what race gets one okay
his is tunic of the champion I wonder if
you think there's only one set or you
think there's more more stuff unlocks I
really hope there's more than one set
you want to check ax pommel nope no red
version what Chewie
what about talismans did you take
Hausman no I can't believe they're doing
another thing that's hilarious
I like when they get played oh oh
exchange the fully upgraded for oh you
so you have that so that's something you
can upgrade to right amulet of the cuz
cuz say F wow that's it so you don't
have the Amulet of I don't even know you
don't even of production where would I
even get that if I just missed it to be
honest who knows that's cool
well maybe um maybe we'll get more if
that was a dodge animate and the dodge
amulet or talisman then yeah you
probably dismissed it as possible you
can't buy anything dude I know I can't
so okay so let's like it let me bring us
back I think I got less forcing or wait
maybe you guys want to see all that
maybe I should go bottom right
oh yeah bottom right I can move the pit
so what can I get maybe I could get one
on the stream here well seven more
playing you got more slaps leg how many
how many Oh apparently you have Casa
veer already you activated it are you
sure
well maybe we do maybe he just didn't
upgrade his amoled all the way yet so
then that's why he can't do the perfect
version yet
stay down and you have more than one
game saved at a time I want to say yeah
you can yeah yeah it's just manual saves
just gotta be careful
how do I start a new game plus it says
ignition maecius Mesabi well as long as
you beat the game you should have that I
think that's a caveat at least new game+
will show up on the main menu actually
and you should be able to see it and you
can pick a new game plus and then choose
your difficulty you follow yeah you
fellow oh hello more people
that's a good question GP I would assume
that the story probably stays the same
despite having the new items that'd be
kind of too hard to rewrite some stuff
because of what we have I was dumb
yeah some dude bet the perfect armors go
up to level 10 I think where were we
stuck at 8 or 9 can't remember oh my god
it's interesting like I said watching
just other people play because I like
barely throw my hat except people I love
throwing the axe I shouldn't I feel like
I do it too often
oh where the FaceCam let me bring that
back good call sorry I wanted you guys
to be able to see the menus appreciate
it does it feel any different than
before um not really right I mean like
other than just like getting reactivated
like I think it's it's been a while yeah
slap slag slag over here over here sorry
you would never followed that oh man
this small box small box maybe don't you
come from there no I'm countin on it
little slag yes there's a new equipment
rarity level this mr. Justin arrows as
mentioned I think someone said level 10
which is like I think they call it
perfect there is new equipment you can
be the cod of war apparently Elaine L
that's a it's a new armor set that you
could buy from Brock I'm sure when we
find sindri I wouldn't be shocked and
maybe he hopefully unlocks another one
but we don't know rebuilding your runes
we're playing on the normal give me a
balanced experience just because again
we we haven't played in a while and
there's pretty rough sliding's on give
me a challenge oh yeah you were gonna go
there but you didn't freeze the thing
that doohickey
Oh
faces a magic you can find again I've
also uh put in the blog post a couple
times so you guys can always look at
that to just check out all the stuff
that they've added so we're about six
slag scraps away from buying one piece
of the new armor the cod of war oh I'm
so dumb hopefully a hynek's it's hard to
say well don't know if there's gonna be
new armor there either but hoping hoping
there's a couple new sets that would be
cool ones not too shabby too you know we
can't can't be too upset if there's only
one you said armor I know like everyone
wants more but you know sometimes that's
just not the case let's be happy that we
got a new game plus mode for free right
mm-hmm call up daddy
that's that whoo slapping the boss yeah
we're getting closer
I feel like you should have gotten more
no maybe are you getting warnings yeah
you can get it from the store if you
don't have it yet there's multiple
places that you can get the game in
man remember this one for the urn for
the to do all hit all their rooms it's
kind of annoying wait there is it here
yeah there's a there's one that you have
to do though like you know destroy the
little pots into the wall phase them
through the wall no problem
I don't Ken
have you guys beat the Valkyries I have
I think we robbers beat a couple can be
won a couple bit over there
just get this real quick you can get me
show the cod armor again please you can
actually use the DVR function Dominic
and if you scrub back about I don't know
a couple minutes to where we find Brock
you'll be able to see the armor set I
think that's the one that they had put
in the blog post where when you step on
the you know health stones or rage
stones it causes explosions now how big
those explosions are who knows but maybe
it's like a mortar strike or artillery
strike I just don't know how often I
would be able to trigger that where the
stones would be in the right place
unless the explosions are just massive
I'll stick with my Valkyrie Valkyrie arm
ring oh nice I like the nipple home
alarm where because it you can level it
up pretty high there's definitely one up
there
I think there's like a thing there's a
bunch it just depends if you want to do
that here or not
what did those things have slaps
slagging it or no SCAP slaps keg I don't
know
I don't recall I wasn't fully paying
attention you should check well then
you're gonna have to do this mini puzzle
there was one that I had the hardest
time finding and I don't know in this
area yeah it was like below or somewhere
in between yet that like feather through
or I don't remember they can be tricky
10 I don't know about Kate I don't know
about that cane but sure I guess if you
feel that way
yes Redis house as long as you beat the
game and you're doing you game plus yes
you get the Chaos displays right off the
bat like spikes your god but spike still
hurt they hooked and then yeah now I
don't yeah I struggles with that one for
a long time I don't know why my brain
was not working
hi the Valkyrie set is pretty Opie with
runic with the runic cooldown yeah
considering I like runic abilities and
maybe I should just wear that but I
think I was like in nickel home so much
that I know nope no scabs lag oh you
don't have max rage oh you don't
dang Rob don't don't do hey guys it's
okay I get to I get to judge him you
guys kind of get to judge them to you
judge me oh I will trials of Musel hi
and we're super fun there was one that
was super annoying though I think was
like though it either was a timed one or
don't get hit 1 or something I hate it
was there circles
yes you had to kill enemies in a certain
just push them into the circles that's
what I did
- had trouble with that one yeah it's
alright no no the nor nerd chests just
have health arrange upgrades got you boy
yeah so let's not go for those anymore
but uh yeah now you got he's got oh yeah
I beat the game how come I don't see the
game Plus have you updated judicata
Jones maybe try like closing the
application then reopening it and then
checking for an update or maybe try
restarting your your console that could
also do it those are those are some
things to try
nope what's up Stephanie are you mister
stuff like nailed it nailed it
great job thanks so much great job
thanks dude thanks no problem thanks
Eric
yeah we get in there I want that chest
that that thought of war thought of war
chest yeah we want that cloud of war how
about how about we keep playing until we
get a cot of war peace and then we use
the cloud of war peace and that's where
we're in the stream I think we still
have 50 like 10 to 15 before we would
hit the hour-and-a-half mark I think I
think we could do it in half an hour I
think especially since you're gonna be
able to explore around right soon yeah
valuable no oh not yet for some reason I
thought you were like there you're only
like four five I'm five away
yeah that's not that pass something I
don't know now we're gonna be paranoid
all the time like I did okay you got a
face of magic time I'll give you a phase
of magic way that look like this game is
beautiful though it's so good-looking
oh yeah this guy so here's what we could
do well I guess we'll see skip it but
like if we would want to wait till 23 I
think the difference is 23 for the chess
piece that's 24 like do you get anything
I mean the chess piece looks pretty cool
Oh got it fair okay well let's see how
how we get in the next one half an hour
let's see how far you get in half an
hour and then we'll gauge it based off
that
oh yeah that stuff
I would love that too John no idea we'll
get that anything that would be pretty
sweet we could have our big showdown I
mean they definitely teased that it
uh-oh
put yourself in a corner nobody puts
Kratos in the corner nobody
I hate corners
what no that was a good good dodge good
dodge I don't have the heart to fight
all this again you can do it don't mask
the truth you just got to remember you
have all the abilities now those so you
get to go to town on all of them like
yeah I think we had your axe the first
time now you could like swap through the
blades you can just like trim them down
a bit you know it's like really given
the business to see like Rob's even
forgetting that he had I don't really
like using them much yeah but use it for
that least of unique ability yeah yeah
but the one runic abilities not gonna
work though if I can work right done now
get up son
oh you just play to get through the
story that's fair you can always play on
story mode to you I don't master to but
I guess if you're in it more for story
and not for all the combat or the action
then yeah there's probably not as much
reason for you to get back into it
folder who the boulder did work it did
it really did actually he's actually
dead yeah
god I love that shield we want slap scag
we want slaps keg what do you guys want
to see in the sequel whoo that's tough
oh wow there's a purple oh yeah you got
to loot the boss he had a bunch of stuff
let's see if he has anything fun and you
got the purple drop there it looks like
or not oh just soft skip this thing yeah
probably
well you might need it for the raid I
think there's something up here at Reyes
get up there new weapon would be cool I
guess new moves definitely new moves new
armor new armor yeah maybe a hairdo no
rats read that well read that by
yourself dad can't read you have two
files that are completed you get to pick
which save file you want crew it forced
Rob to pick one of the saves he had to
go into New Game+ with so I'm guessing
you should have the option as well to
pick the save that you would like to use
or if you're worried you can always save
or cloud save and you know I knew it was
a ball Hammad says one regret was me
playing this game way too fast I should
have taken my time to explore more but
the story was too interesting one of the
best games ever played yeah I actually
was so scared ho mob that I was rushing
through everything that I basically did
every side thing I possibly could like
leading up to the end of the story and
it was worth it it was fun be better son
who knows professor Pi we're hoping so
little no time for we're looking for
slaps gag we got time for these Ravens
that Ravens got a slap scag we don't
need it hack silver just what we needed
damn you're a literal homewrecker that
house oh yeah that's true as Savio
mentioned Egyptian mythology was another
choice of team had to make other than
Norse myth yeah they think I saw some
screenshots recently of some of the
stuff from the Egyptian like kind of
like a first set of like artwork or
whatever that they were working with
yeah I know it's free New Game+ yes
right if you have the game make sure you
update it and you'll get new game+ for
free that was not much of a skip skipped
like one second
that I'm not sure of Shira when not sure
[Music]
and did you already see the perfect
where dr where you have for a trace we
looked at one perfect armor that was
various earlier when we were talking to
brock Josh nope
I sold the game should I buy it again
cuz I'm not sure if New Game+ is worth
it I mean that's up to you if we sold it
it's hard to say if you should buy it
again just for New Game+ but I don't
know it's just right
dang it I don't guy I honestly don't
remember I wouldn't have to be that way
was it a Deadhead
whereas
Oh
coming to you I'm coming when do you
think cyberpunk 2077 will be released
not this year next year hopefully I
don't know maybe next year doubtful I
would say
no way spider-man pieces can you never
know I mean it's too early to tell
there's only seen a little bit of
spider-man I'm guessing you mean that
John from the like perspective of like
Game of the Year or something so do you
think this is Kratos his last mythology
to kill boy like I was carrying this
wounded pig that we've been hunting for
so long I wanna eat it we need slaps gag
though for real
for reals oh is it too early for the for
the game Spock shout out its later be
deaf yeah for those who you don't know I
mean it was an e3 a few years ago we're
like one of our Alex Newhouse one of our
editors for news like somehow thought I
didn't the boy didn't have a name yet
right so that what you just called him
Charlie yeah for some reason like called
a minute in the article at raius Charlie
at the time and like Cory Barra log the
director like was laughing about it he's
like for some reason GameSpot like on
some stage called Charlie so I guess
he's Charlie now but they put that in
where they named the turtle here Charlie
so if you see that reference I heard
that reference that is actually and we
actually have Cory bar log himself
saying that it is a call out to GameSpot
calling a trade Charlie which is cool so
if you haven't watched that video it's
pretty cool you can still find that
article too it's all it's like on our
site I want to say it was like gosh
probably like 2014 because this games
been in developing collect that white
petal flower man I am having this
feeling you're not gonna get enough slag
what do I do now I gotta go get the
flower and yeah from the garden do you
think Odyssey will be up to mark I am
Not sure uh I will say I'm sure there'll
be you know will will at some point be
chatting more about it you know I
wouldn't be shocked to see it beside the
gamescom or something like that this
week so sitting against watch if you
want to learn more about Odyssey
potentially I mean I like what they did
with origins so if they build on that
and continue that path I'm sure it'll be
you know where is this are there new
runic attacks also not that I know of
Shura do you know first thing this uh
isn't it on the other side not here but
like you wrap around no no no yeah yeah
that way that's why no wait or yeah I
thought you had to go around ish or
maybe not can you upgrade the axe and
blades more um it's a good question I'm
not 100% sure don't let me see it let me
see I think you probably can though see
all says is explore new customization
options with more powerful versions of
existing armor Talman and in Chapman so
maybe not weapons
all I know is I want to be the Cata boar
armor looks sick I want to drop in
artillery strike what that's what it
says it does causes big explosions all
right
oh maybe I can get get some in here
right yeah I mean if I have enough some
of it might be locked out though wait I
don't know I have I have some
what a great compass imagine if you had
a compass like that in life go this way
you'll succeed oh that's a thing I
wonder your thumb you know how like
there's that bramble I wonder if they
let you through if you have the right
attack you know what I mean yeah because
you need a trace wrong so like I I don't
think I think what's gating me also are
his arrows how do you cuz I - well
lightning one yeah how do you switch it
like I'm doing it I don't think it's all
dpad right yeah I thought it was on the
d-pad yeah me too so I don't think I can
do it yet you keep your money right you
kept your money yeah and you yeah when
we keep your experience can you show up
your new shield
I don't think we well no there is when
you says you get a new shield skin or
they receive and use shield skin with
starting a game on you game plus and
then you can unlock another one when you
complete a new game plus on give me got
a war well how I get down here is it's
this way
so we can try to show the shield skin
later how do I get my gear in new game+
it's already on your character so you
should already have it we didn't have to
do anything different
yeah come on you're like three or he
gave robbed three finally once though
yep only one damn it
unless that was just a steel that you
also go ooh you can't get that though
right
no oh so the water has to high to high F
alright we can travel around with a boat
and probably find some on the island you
have to lower the water first though
no but there's still side quests though
I'm saying in the in the in the bigger
hub world also that would be the chaos
play it's not facts though you're right
will that work
I doubt it if everything else is being
gated I'm gonna say probably not yeah it
would be glowing I think anyways OOP no
I don't know if this is though
but it's not I only have my XP and sober
really oh we got perfect talisman of
vitality sweet
so wheat oh that was one of the things
you could have upgraded to that that he
was like oh if you have I think if you
have that anyways cool all right we got
one new piece of gear was probably
pretty clutch for a higher difficulties
what was that red chest the red chest is
pretty standard it just had the new
upgrade material hello I'm new here how
can you get a shield you don't you start
with a shield yeah that's an interesting
question allowed you have no idea you
having to unlock that ability yet you
need that flame thing
thank you guys all for tuning in if you
didn't know against what live goes live
every morning at 11 a.m.
um we play various games Monday to
Friday you know new releases new updates
previews betas all that fun stuff
so come hang out with us hit that sub
button if you haven't but tomorrow just
so you guys know we start a little later
than normal tomorrow's gonna be 11:30
start we are gonna have a special guest
in nice I mean I'll be playing I think
the monster hunters generation demo so
come back 11:30 tomorrow hang out with
us boy read it
yes giving oh really it's fine I like
that our moose wilheim and Nikola Haim
already unlocked I don't think so I
think you might be able to see it
possibly but I'm gonna say it's probably
not because a lot of stuff I still gated
I mean you still have all your stuff but
like for example even though we got rid
of some of the bramble near the house it
was large and we couldn't climb it also
we couldn't access the valkyries right
away so yeah converses hello guys really
liked this game one of the best in the
year yep I have to agree with that so
far one of the best games I played so
far this year but many more games to
come was a new rarity called I want to
say it's perfect
you can share that cod armor again ago
yeah what's going to sweet now
[Music]
magic really nervous but what if what if
Red Dead Redemption to is really good
though can be really good but you could
upgraded that regardless I think you got
to go one over yet don't do it don't do
it an upgrade gonna use your slaps like
no no I know we know but you can upgrade
your axe see if your axe
requires a slaps leg later one over no
one over cuz I said you could oh no you
just got frozen flame might as well
right
yeah sure there's no it's only used for
that I think you just weren't I don't
think you were at max level yet that's
why I think six is what you could do
before
okay keep going yeah we gotta get that
caught of war guy get that cat of war
limb that kind of life all right
I know rebuilding there's a couple
people in the office looking forward to
shadows of the Tomb Raider I know Mike
will be just cause poor as well he has a
good shout that's not a raven I don't
care any sidetracked I am are you going
to go around the boat stuff are you
gonna go to so you can you there's
nothing there's nothing to explore yet
really yeah not with the first water are
you sure know about that should we look
around no all right I'll take it cuz
like that's you can get to that but
that's not gonna give you anything
how big is that update someone said
about 866 megabytes why don't you just
do you and go to alpine then
yow was I'm gonna come he said that I
don't have the lightning arrows off the
bat now that I think about it
yeah Oh what you said watch her back no
I just don't like listening to my son oh
god no I'm not doing great all right
that's it
what the hell
he's an exploder that'll feel fibers of
black ops for which to buy I think it's
a way too soon to tell oh my god why are
these guys doing such a hard time is
their level 5 because you don't like
switching weapons
yeah there's new armor there's no new
weapons that we know sounds like you do
have to get the ciphers again oops
shouldn't I be able to yeah you can aim
right check over here
no let's just keep going
I guess oh those guys those guys have
fun yeah they're super fun I've never
played this game well if you wear up a
little bit of spoilers camper but we're
playing a game plus mode is really good
you should try it out if you haven't if
you're even interested as mentioned for
me and I think Rob to one of the the
best games we played so far in this year
I think so
there's help there where I like couch
co-op well maybe if you have a switch
you should maybe play that Diablo 3
there's no date on the announcement yet
but uh we put up some switch gameplay if
you want to check that out this morning
and we also had a little chat about it
me and Alessandro just about that
version and you know having that oh this
is a bad idea
that was a bad idea come here
pax greater than blade I don't dispute
that I'm just saying that my play style
definitely helped because I was spamming
runic ability so I would always kind of
switch but I would favor the axe as well
personally oh there's the thing for it
put your knife into it you think there's
a slaps slaps keg probably not yeah I
think it is
you think this top that it's dang just a
safely
all right we go this one got that a we
we have them already
my bad which way we go this way
think that way I think that way because
thanks anvil one gaming that's a clutch
link there this is my first time I
channel well thanks for stopping my
appreciate it who knows I think all this
story stuff will be the same though
nothing is gonna change because of like
what we have yes which sure some people
will probably make the argument that
should but you know that's kind of hard
to does he have anything different no I
did the opposite Nemus
I used the blades for crowd control oh
what's that
go back real quick do you see that
generate legendary oh my god I totally
just forgot about our traces a special
special yeah you're looking there was I
don't know where you're just at but
there was like like create I'll go back
oh shoot too fast no not there go one
over another one another one another one
huh there was something that was like
upgrade like legendary enchantment or
something I don't know what screen
you're in though that sucks that I
couldn't stop you sooner
sorry I'm just so fast no no no wasn't
in that I think he was like an upgrade
no no it looks like something like where
you could make an enchantment or
something because that's supposed to be
like one of the things too I think
tight good work son
yeah cuz it says push the boundaries of
combat by converting certain talismans
and armor sets into enchantments
creating combinations which are not
possible in standard playthrough dang it
do you guys play any other games that we
play a bunch of other games out during
the streams as mentioned we stream
Monday to Friday at 11 a.m. and yeah we
play variety of games we will play games
that just came out we'll play alphas
betas will preview games if we have them
early oh my god we'll die sometimes from
throwing boulders you know happens it
happens
oh yeah full health now
yeah I mean it's I get some of you guys
asking about trophies but yeah there's
no new trophies and you know kind of how
it goes right this is just a way to
experience and enjoy the game again
that's how I look at it although I guess
I didn't technically Platinum it either
but I just didn't want to do the Ravens
back here
can you play warframe I have not
admittedly just because I didn't I
played a lot of destiny and I just
couldn't get into kind of like like a
leveling and doing all that again also I
heard the systems are a little bit hard
and you don't have someone kind of
guiding you
a little bit so yeah but I've heard good
things
there's health down there ooh we're
proving sick when I start to play this
that's it yeah definitely yeah we're
getting there to become the cod of war
sure yeah I'm not sure on all of them
because he still had some rage that he
couldn't wire so I didn't pay attention
the first time he grabbed the first nor
near chest may I have to look from the
other side as in like on the completely
other side it's never as hard as you
think it is I always made it like way
harder than it was and it's like never
what do you think it is yeah you might
have to see it from the side yeah I bet
you it's on the side that's what I would
say as advice to anyone if you're if
you're ever stuck on something like that
you don't over complicate things because
the puzzles albeit somewhere interesting
and a little harder than others they're
usually more straightforward than you
think
so re - next year remake can't wait for
that yeah there's again a couple of
people in the office definitely looking
forward to that - more right no - more
should maybe be a little getting this
area hard to say ooh ooh no you can't
though but this one oh yeah you can get
that one light it on fire and see if you
can I guess hopefully you can you might
be locked out of it though by now
type hope you're not locked out nice
okay cool so some of the stuff seems
like you can get to in some of it it
seems like you're tied down to story
alright one more
una mas una mas for caught of war dang
so close you love poison I love it I've
just joined I've beaten the game ready
but can't access the new game plus how
do I do it well make sure you updated
your god of war
there should be should have been an
update for you this morning at 10 a.m.
Pacific which is about closing it on
three hours oh no yeah er no this is
update I'm thinking about sure for us
we're closing in on two hours but
hopefully if we can get that last thing
we can just mess around with the armor
for life call it go more volume please
you're super quiet for me even at max
okay ooh I but I bumped our audio a bit
so okay that'll help you out and game
game sorry camper a game where ninety
nine nine three nines actually I like
that you guys reach at you guys are
quiet is more but again you know alright
should we get it yeah let's do that wolf
because they wanted louder I can turn
down ours that's fine now I just turned
down our monitor level and then bump us
up a bit
yeah should be fine I've updated but
it's not on the menu have you beat the
game yet mark I don't know if beating it
necessarily is one of the caveats but it
would make sense because then you know
you wouldn't start a new game plus so
you beat the game when is this out ask
Ben Ben G skits it's actually out
already you can download it as long as
you update forgot to ask how do you have
read to your gear we're playing on you
game plus mode digital Reapers this is
the new as Rob's about to buy he's gonna
buy one of the new pieces of armor I
don't know which piece torso weight so
read the read the prompts this one give
here's a protective barrier that's
boring yeah we want that can get the
explosions if Curtis is help that's all
using hailstones will grab ray and if
rage well what oh whatever
grant health what if you're maxed on
both that's useless anyways oh so the
chest costs the most right it's 23 and
we can't get it that sucks that's the
coolest one it's 24 right creates a
powerful explosion no you can get one if
you want or just wait oh dude that look
it doesn't look sick
should we what you're selling I don't
know it's up to you you got eight
minutes what if we get four won't you
try because like the other armor pieces
aren't gonna be like they the the which
we call it the effects aren't as good as
the chest so we might as well not buy
the other pieces right yeah so close
I've started a new game on another
difficulty does that nullify my progress
no I mean did you beat it the first time
though on the other difficulty cuz I
mean you would have had to have got
through once to even be able to I think
trigger new game so if you start it
again on a new difficulty then you know
you still got to beat the game right so
new I mean I wouldn't think you would
want to start a new game plus without
actually already having items
you know come here don't do it don't do
it don't do it
boys an yourself okay oh God right into
it said how they have blacksmith or did
you spell that round oh man she is doing
his work all right okay she's a crafty
one home she's crafty doesn't matter
that you're enraged wow she's a literal
hacker oh my god and this is where we
end the stream ladies and gentlemen know
she sees into the matrix get some get
closer
got her we did it we did it ladies and
gentlemen what's up JD King WWE what did
you think about last night's SummerSlam
I was shocked by the ender that's for
sure when they play co-op you can't play
co-op in this game I mean I like I am I
am at Reyes in spirit animal form I
guess like I I live through him as a
proxy so basically Rob's telling me to
get closer to shooter and I'm like dude
dad stop sucking my life and he'll
already God boy so like think of at
Reyes as your range last caster because
that's basically what he is companion
love from dinesh thanks Joker Joker
I think sterner with arrows first yeah
he was trying also he doesn't have the
shock arrows yet just because that's
apparently somehow gated which is weird
oh good parry oh great parry don't be
near that thing or give him the okay
that's a total exam he's gonna regen
health it's open world right um parts of
it can be seen that way but it's not
like a true watch out it's not like a
true open world right is that is that
fair what I'm saying I don't know I
guess it's hard to describe ooh some
slaps keg all right oh it's worth it it
was worth it worth worth worth what's
the new gear you can become the cod of
war and you can upgrade some new
talismans apparently and as I had read
earlier it says push the brown geez of
combat for converting certain talismans
and armor sets and enchantments I got to
see what that even means that sounds
crazy though yeah keep burning we like
it you think you'll get another one here
you know you got a sturdy schedule of
determination real sturdy
how do you get your items back in new
game+ I mean I don't know we didn't do
anything special to get her to get our
items right you just had them at the
start right yeah nothing nothing was
yeah I am this is what you need to be
doing now you switch to the don't worry
you just wanted to trigger that sick
effect the magma shield now you're gonna
oh yeah you get to ride on him and like
use him as a just slap like I got the
vehicle what's up hey you know what's
funny um I think I told someone that you
could do this and they didn't know and
they were like oh I thought I was just
beating them up was like no dude you can
use him to like beat them up they're
kind of low on HP just FYI there's a lot
of enemies around you - whoa the game
you got a war be more difficult because
I played it before and I was it was
literally very difficult it's even more
difficult now because I think from
reading it all the enemies start at
level seven I don't know if it'll be
even more difficult but if it was
difficult to begin with for you then
it's gonna definitely be difficult again
damn it
nice was this guy doing
it's just showing shilling you know
getting his life back
got him Thank You Joker Joker appreciate
it
could use some new finisher animations
but beggars can't be choosers yeah we
kind of talked about that too earlier
double og would be nice to kind of you
know have you know all I think at the
end of the day we always want more but
as gamers I think but you know it's cool
just to have this as a mode to have it
you know playable you know it's free so
going down with it yeah that's cool in
itself I think we take for granted some
other things we're actually getting but
as you mentioned you know like you said
beggars can't be choosers or so we're so
close I know let's keep going all right
although are you gonna reach the summit
before you think you even get all of it
don't you have to go there to the smoke
yeah
thank I you can just get this sweep
that's another fun feature if you didn't
know is it special
you getting hit up meeting at 1:00 oh
it's Navitus nap do you want to keep
playing I can try I want to get there
and then I could we can always just call
it - I mean yeah put some gameplay up
later yeah we can always put some off
later anyone called there seems like a
good time yeah how much how close were
you pretty close probably wait you have
35 wait what
whew one of those boxes must have had
more than one it didn't say oh [ __ ] oh I
guess we can go check it out please your
meeting with Chris I'll tell Chris
you're gonna be a couple minutes late
yeah thankfully it's no longer under
water why is that creature in the day no
one knows he just appeared one one day
skip skip skip skip skip I can't I know
[Music]
this Tomi I don't know how many rob has
I have a good amount but I think I'm
still missing the feel my my character
visit Reyes Avenue warmers he has one
yes well one that we know of
we're not sure if like maybe you get
farther than the game that it triggers
any other armors coming out our new
armors or not but you know off the start
off the start we have the one set for
Kratos and then one for a trace no Brock
I mean Sindri want you can you take a
door is there a magic door I have to
like do this I think I have what I don't
know I think I'm being forced I have to
like go to I was a nifflheim River elf
I'm you mean I'll fine yeah but Brock's
still there though Brock will sell you
the armor maybe why not well Sindri
wasn't there yeah in my part of the
story beat though right
rocks always at the hub world where you
have that you can just use the door I
think because she's involved right now
she'd there she's guiding me that I
think we're locked I think I have to
like oh she's got a new ability was
soaked in the lightest kit we can that's
correct
those hours you played won't go to waste
Oh chances nope he won't be there Nick
what do you do did you can plus well
hopefully I beat the game already and
then you do the upgrade and then or
update sorry not upgrade update and
should have it and now we're screwed
apparently well find out we'll find out
you're gonna find out right now
because we're basically here God if we
paid attention we wouldn't have had to
engage that quest I mean who knows
whatever I'm so close
Brock Lesnar is waiting for you in there
I hope so
still can't believe again the outcome of
SummerSlam last night do you keep H s do
you think HS stands for it's not coming
to mind how many hours have you guys
been streaming out we started at 11 so
about two now so you can't go through
those doors god no no you can't so you
can't go up there you can't you know
she's with me you I have to continue
with this I know lady okay
I could do that
that is would be insane there's that and
not for me do you really want to be Paul
Heyman Boxley hacks over yeah yet hack
silver does carry over so close
Oh hex over sorry yeah come on come on
me caught of war call of duty of war
yeah yeah dog my back would be hurting I
mean once work we're closed well once
you get to alpha high alpha Homer done
Alfheim Alfheim excuse me penny he'll
show up yeah I think sindri is the one
who's there
it's not here I know damn you Brock snap
it on the job that's right because they
can't see each other right so later it's
like a story thing right no you just
have you're just being forced to follow
around so they have to like let's go
lady
have you qward side work man
once you clean the light of all time
infuse the like how she had to
delicately take it off her bow but she
can just magically take putting it on to
hit anyways love from Bangladesh thank
you appreciate it
Samuel we're so close it's so close so
close
this temple is me he's like a psychic
Magda he's like our three execution mode
is just a like spank you've been a bad
boy is that your companion yes it's also
his son Oh what's up Antonio Brown
didn't know you were a GameSpot fan Toni
- taps
what's up Lawrence Woodside we're good
oh look Santa Monica studios in here hey
is Cory there what's up Cory we're
actually about to wrap up we're really
just trying to get this caught of war
armor to be honest just the chest piece
that chest piece come on yeah hot skip
it should be a good skip yeah instead
turn the wheel to our actual destination
you're ready found the new armor you
don't have to find it it's in the shop
just in the blacksmith once you unlock
the blacksmith you'll then be able to
purchase it but you have to find enough
of the new material the slab scag is
that right yes nope SCAP slags I know
that's games land and you just find
those throughout the world in the chests
and we finally accrued 35 of which at
some point we got more than one in one
of the boxes or whatever reason and so
now we can buy the armor because it's 24
slap nope I said that wrong again scoffs
like God it's a little no I didn't get
wrong SCAP slag slag slaps gag instead
days Mondays
hey made more since the first time okay
what did alright thought you're just
saying in terms of like how much stuff
we got to go through that's a good
question yeah if anything guys give the
shout outs to or give your thoughts more
Oh got more yeah that's sick I didn't
see how many we had 35 we maybe yeah I
mean if Santa Monica Studios is still in
chat I'm saying that's not the real one
I was not that's a crime we're saying
[ __ ] oh that's unfortunate
yeah damn we got got pretty good play
though pretty good play pretty good play
skip skip skip skip skip skip alright so
in theory
you think he'll be here it's just a ways
up 10 girls fight win hey leave him
alone oh it's good knowing you with the
turf war I said dark ELLs and the light
elves what was that
man I don't know how you use this thing
that's so distracting oh this is it I
love this one
are you sure yeah okay cuz there's two
right now that's not the one there's one
that's runaway right that was it
Oh was it I think there's two versions
of this oh yeah half off
half off deal we're getting close
are you yeah we're good all right cuz
you're gonna be later than ten minutes
that I said that you're gonna be late
all right let's get to a chest armor
chest armor
we got 44 now that was nine we got nine
from you can buy another piece cuz only
20 21 sick equip that oh look at that
you you're not your fashions is not good
right now are you gonna do the grips or
do using waste we're just the grips in
the waist yeah that seems to be better
than the other one to me yeah I actually
know that it might not be true I don't
know they're both about the same to me I
mean the chest was the best piece
probably in terms of like what it did
like see this thing doesn't even have
runic I don't zooming wait used to waste
all no runic Eric doesn't use you know
all right let's do it
I always do so now every time you step
on stones it should cause like an
explosion
I agree Cindy I hope his knee or me no
we got to ride the boat I just wanna
fight some stuff
that's true they're dark it's a light
elf pedestrian they didn't even have a
weapon is it just me or is it my
Infinity Gauntlet gone oh it shouldn't
be Rodney but I haven't tried on my
Savior
so it's a good question oh look there's
those teardrops still that's interesting
you think you get more stats get it
hurry be hilarious if it was like okay I
started a new game with no one finding a
calling anymore oh that's kind of sad if
that's true it was one of the best
talismans you know Thanos took it that's
probably that's probably true I hear
voices I should just take off do you
want to keep playing I will try to I
don't even know how to I haven't played
at all I don't know what I'm doing but
we'll figure it out where the buttons
there somewhere
I buckle one Rose gonna go to his
meeting too late
else coochy coochy coochy coochy I skip
can't skip alright guys I haven't played
this whole time it's been a while
there's a new armor better I think just
has a new property that hasn't existed
before Mathias see what I can do for you
guys I want to change his abilities so
bad I don't this is not DLC this is just
new game+
oh you moved yet all right Rob's back
here we go hold on let me bring your mic
back there you go all right
Rob's gonna show off this armor which
hopefully only take a few minutes once
we can engage in combat base by the way
that's not the real Santa Monica studio
apparently so that's what crime says at
least oh it's cool
BAM you're a great driver and I was
distracted by the beautiful sight the
Vista do something kid it does look
pretty cool what do you think reminds me
something like someone in Game of
Thrones will be wearing back to the boat
Bobby you could probably say that kind
of thing almost like the fake feathers
yeah it looks cool I like it it's always
weird when you don't have a full set
though is your favorite hi Rob bye
Felicia
later Luis oh it is them is what someone
saying I'm so we're legit what is going
on here this chat is blowing me away I
can't who's who who are you some type of
all right I'm gonna go back and say it's
them it's the development YouTube
account all right crime I'm gonna put
you on timeout Oh Cory actually had a
great presentation on the development of
the game at Def Con yeah I think that
was just the other day was that just the
other day I think because they were
talking they were short like I said
earlier they're showing off the like
Egyptian kind of like first concept art
stuff or whatever dub club technique
what is new game+ it lets you basically
play the game again except you get to
keep all your progression your items
your skills your here we go things than
that all right here we go we got it find
some stones you got to make them drop
some stones okay yeah that's how you're
gonna get them to do it
god I love that movie cause aren't you
are we aren't we able to infinitely play
and you can Plus yes you can go on as
many times as one and we are on a ps4
pro as freezers mentioned nice freeze
them freeze them up come down you love
that movie I love that move oh I love
this move - it keeps getting stuck in
the bushes nope Oh
eventually you'll get him how did they
drop anything I need to see these code
of works
oh there's nope that's nothing man no we
are not playing on the hardest
difficulty we're just playing on
balanced right now if you were curious
all right nope that's funny Santa Monica
Studios just replied to one of the
viewers but the viewers name is holy
[ __ ] so it's like @ holy [ __ ] Hart whoa
more guys all right yeah man nothing's
free here just cuz you alerted them by
raising up the part of the bridge or
whatever Oh back problems
I guess I should take the time to say
thank you to Santa Monica whew yeah one
of my favorite my favorite game so far
20:18 hands down oh really
not really I'm playing it on give me a
challenge good awesome yeah pick the
difficulty which is best for you or
funnest for you or most challenging it's
great to have options
Oh so see that that might be a good
example of maybe some of the the new
parrying being a little bit more
absolutely instable what it used to be
what is this so every time you pop a
rage stone oh you should probably
probably enchanted too by the way both
your pieces probably a good thing they
do that would probably be a good thing
to do yeah
so another thing was like you could
quickly swap your enchantments but we
haven't tried that either but there's no
new trophies hungy not that I know but
Santa Monica Studios is in here so you
know they said thank you for playing oh
no thank you thank your none of this
matters right now I'm sorry just giving
him a hard time Dan you went from
purples to reds how does it feel it
feels so good hate love wait no he's
close did you actually ever build your
character certainly like stat wise I
would try yeah I would try to yeah nice
okay
damn look at that looks good
whoops what's up nice oh yeah my
favorite I guess in Santa Monica Studios
in here no you know anything about one
of the viewers were saying that they
didn't have their Infinity Gauntlet or
the gauntlet of the shattered ages off
their new game plus mode start is that
something that might be a user error on
his part where maybe he just doesn't see
it or is that something that you guys
might have actually not given us coming
forward I don't know War Eagle
my guess is maybe ten maybe it goes over
ten though not sure oh isn't there a
should I go try to do this what's up
isn't there a what you call none of you
call like an elite but like a what are
those portal rip tear a rift hair or
realm tear around the chair let's think
we do that okay it's on the island right
I think it's right there
good luck to you sir usually they're
like two levels higher like seven so
surprised seven we even eight well
double check with the team thank Santa
see so to Rodney they're gonna find out
oh this is good slap yes yeah yeah
what's the oh here he is looking like
the skill tree is the same did you do
anything yeah look at me now
wait what I thought was supposed to
cause an explosion it kind of did I
missed it
but it wasn't oh there's another stone
over there all right let's let's let's
watch it again it gave you the
protective barrier no but you have the
chest isn't the chest the one that gives
the explosions how do you engage it
though I thought it was just like the
moment you stepped on a yeah it using a
hell stone or a stone creates a powerful
explosion that inflicts frost and burn
damage to all nearby enemies maybe it's
cuz there's no nearby enemies yeah s
play uh plays the cow from the start
yeah Jonathan we're playing a new game
plus so we have all of our equipment or
upgrades talismans and Chapman's all
that stuff you just have to start the
game over but you have everything
progress progress is progresses through
progress goes through I can't talk show
new armor we're wearing the new armor
why was Infinity Gauntlet removed from
there they're actually finding out
professor PI they're inquiring with the
dev team so we'll have to see hopefully
you'll get an answer that'd be pretty
cool
we're mainly trying to show off this
armor
I'm also mainly trying to check if I
happen to miss any meetings I did oh
what'd I do bad yeah all right
the problem is war war never ends that's
true so we can all play yes CDR MHI you
see I think if you beat the game and you
you have it just download the update
which came out today 10:00 a.m. Pacific
with this out during a half hours ago
get that update a New Game+ should be
about available on the like front screen
the the initial starting screen oh wait
did you fight the rift here oh it's
right in front of it
it's like do this how do I do this
looked like he was trying to lip so I
think power it on and then lift it up
because it's trying to go up right now
and then now you want oh sure it's too
so hey
so AoE acts are effective in gears a
water question right it can be when it's
like the right like when you're fighting
the right mobs I used the blades of
chaos a lot for crowd control know why
maybe we're approaching it wrong maybe
I'm wrong wait I feel like Oh nailed it
now you can open it
it's okay there was a couple where I
struggled dude there were some times
where I was like why can't I land this
it's impossible but like I said it's
always more clear than you think it is
there's always a way around it's not
like an overly complicated thing like oh
yeah I kill them within two minutes no
problem no problem no problem
they didn't they weren't higher level
which is interesting I thought they'd be
higher one more to go or possibly more
actually I don't know I don't remember
if they spawn why I'll go get him at
Reyes oh I've never seen the shield move
there that's cool
see you later you said gears award did I
do it I don't know if I did I apologize
I am that was that not two minutes yeah
it was he did it okay that wouldn't be
there if you didn't tie it tested the
realms so that's a reason to do some
realm terrors I guess how much do you
have now
nine those are like one and a half more
and you got you got another night a full
piece of cod of war a Niner dick kratos
just turn into the Hulk Hulk smash yeah
when he rages you know one good one
could argue that he is Hulk like I know
to be honest fight get got a war and
starting again plus my favorite attacks
would be AoE
I don't know there's something fun about
the single target though man was this
one of the ones I struggled with Amy I
think I like couldn't for the life of me
figure out why I couldn't hit both of
them or something like that
this one's you had to like move it and
like hit them at the same cuz there's a
third one the third one yeah so things
like that no that looks maybe like that
maybe like that oh so here's the thing
is you have to like get off of it Oh as
it spins back that way yes II so like I
was trying to like oh [ __ ]
close close but no cigar the no cigar
yeah what do I need to uh no you got it
right yeah oh right I think struggle is
real chat oh come on
you could actually if you didn't give up
right away I know
radda fact you actually had a chance
yeah actually the game was gonna give
you a second chance
oh man how embarrassing I think we've
seen worse on this dream ya know
Oh Rob open beta for battlefield is
September 4th you know what day that is
though right I think we could be doing
something wrong no no okay
I don't know am i doing something wrong
I flicked that's it this is right shut
up Petraeus yeah can always give up on
it to be better yeah I know sounds about
right
you could be better that's fair yep
Petraeus heart expressed your same
enthusiasm more so awesome Oh that's the
amulet yeah there you go so you got both
of those now you can upgrade those
that's nice
New York's New York's we have stopped
streaming to twitch for the time being
which is mainly on youtube and also on
GameSpot think I love this one oh look
this guy
bro we use our to use our to try our to
our to throw it's slower though it's
okay guys we got it we got oh but maybe
you would can says that TV with money
tries to yeah cuz it goes straight yeah
it's fine
it just shows you both ways are viable
no problem
alright I'm gonna what let you get one
more fight or something yeah how much
hack silver do we have flat not enough
not enough for the full set
Shane Fox says I beat the game started a
new started a new one on gave me got a
war and I don't see the new game+ helps
Shane have you updated close the app
check for update that doesn't work let
me turn off your console or ps4 turn
that back on see if it's there it should
just be an update so if you beat it you
should have it because it basically will
then pull from your saves to tell asked
like which save you want to like I still
might not use it it doesn't have any
runic power on it excuse me I'm all
about that runic life pretty much
oh so apparently for Rodney and I forgot
the other person in chat to the Infinity
Gauntlet are the shattered ages of the
gauntlet or shattered gauntlet of the
ages should be available so must be like
a bug or something like that
so we'll probably find out more from
Santa Monica studios because it should
be available he says here she just says
can't select it
does it matter what difficulties with
the plus or no Jamie it shouldn't
because you get to pick you get to pick
the difficulty you want to play New
Game+ out
pretty oh yes this armor is sick but
yeah go with the the ruins yeah I mean
like it's cool to have another armor set
that might fit one's playstyle but for
me I think I'm we're just gonna upgrade
my current set armor oh this guy oh my
god was actually really hard for me he
was I don't know why I'm scary too
anyway well no because like yeah for if
you took a hit right yeah yeah and then
like the environment was like different
in here it's it was it was dark and he
would only really be the like you know
light up the world where do you think
you're going nowhere
Oh Cooper oh maybe maybe you try to get
them near you you to get to use the
house something come here boy boys Oh
give me a call of duty' caught of war
the explosion radius is not big but it
looks pretty strong there's your realm
ship will Slamma jamma
will slam jam attacks over you old ex
Silva do they add new armor or anything
else to the plus yes we're wearing some
of the new armor there's also there's
two new get your I don't know if they
knew I think they're just maybe plays of
old am talisman but those were available
also you can upgrade more and yeah we
here's the blog post if you guys are
curious about all the stuff you guys can
get new game+
I've not been able to be the Valkyrie
queen finish the journey though can i
still play game plus also can I go back
to try and beat the Queen wants to start
a new game Santa Monica studio replied
you're going to need to still defeat all
the Valkyries again though I guess
that's safe you start again yeah yeah I
would say try to beat the Queen first
and then do new game+
in my opinion just kind of wrap it up
for you you know and then you know
starting to you after that wonder lamb
is upset that we gave well we didn't
give the game of nine but games so I
gave it a nine yeah we don't do halves
so it was either a nine eight seven ten
six you know and the nine is a very good
score still you know reviews are out
there it's it's you know for you to read
and to to get into and you know some
outlets gave it a 10 something you know
but hey we still think it's a fun game I
like I said one of the best I played
this year 2018 the years not over
obviously but you know today it's one of
my favorites you know that's all that
really matters is if you enjoy the game
I'm sorry that it annoys you you know a
game wasn't necessarily get what you
want it to go oh yeah a realm shift ooh
and you tripped them
so you can get somewhere you need help
anywhere no badly I think it doesn't at
Reyes have like that one arm or said or
something that makes them drop like more
oh I don't know I think so I'm not crazy
maybe check and correct me on that one
I got the white barrier actually that's
a good one what are your guys's favorite
rune exact runic attacks that's what
that's a fun question man can you tell
well the answer is charting the white
bear okay I'm pretty sure it's wrath of
the frost giants which they buff by the
way I can't wait to use it
all right let's use it what's it what's
your wrath of the frost
ancients sorry one below yeah oh do I
have to oh that's not that OH I lied
that's not my favorite I lied I thought
it was that one which one is it uh it
might be fury of the ice troll
wait let me see nope that's not it it's
the one where he slams like overhead and
then like he does it a bunch of times is
that upgrade to an VLEs the one this one
oh no I don't think so no it's not that
oh it's frost giants frenzy yeah it's
that one yes that one I lied
it was frost giants frenzy I'm sad now
what doesn't matter this move is still
the bee's knees in my opinion I have to
wait till hold on yeah that that move
does so much damage interesting sweet so
looks like Santa Monica Studios is gonna
try to work with Rodney here in terms of
trying to see why the Infinity Gauntlet
or shattered gauntlet of the ages is not
working currently in New Game+ so
hopefully we find out more about that so
that we can possibly even you know maybe
I should hit up Santa Monica studio as
well after the stream so that we can I
figure out why that's not working
oops
[Music]
ten
and there's need ten more dude we are
not Eric we're just playing on give me a
balanced experience uh what do you wanna
do now you wanna live over other words I
mean I'm so close man
what the full set doesn't give you
anything different does it I don't know
it's the full set okay John Horry says
the best runic attack is a blast of
hephaestus what rarity is that armor um
I mean it's whatever the new looks like
a new test started at like seven or
eight but I think you still got to
upgrade it nice great work
maybe you'll finally have full rage nope
he's got some hack silver that's
probably a life note and your max don't
lie Freddie
thanks for bringing that up
Rodney appreciate how many new armor is
in new game+ so far Eric we've only seen
one
and once we unlock the blacksmith
through the story we're able to see it
and then once we got enough items we
were able to purchase this she's worried
almost have a full set so it's very cool
this not sure if there's any more I
don't know if Santa Monica Studios wants
to speak on that or not but they are in
the chat so maybe they can answer that
or maybe they'll leave it open-ended and
we'll find out you need your ax
are you guys ready you got a war for
great poppers we may now hey if you guys
didn't know Rob and Mike on Thursdays
they have a stream called great poppers
where they basically put permadeath in
every game actually this would be a fun
one I wouldn't make you I wouldn't want
you guys to play on gave me got a war
because that probably too much but I
would say give me a challenge is fair
fair game you know yeah I would say
maybe dude a new game or a brand new
game though yeah and not a new game plus
yeah but that's my two cents and then
besides you you're making a no plated
updated like second list right or like
almost like oh that's different yeah I
told you there's two animations Oh
interesting
yeah oh wow you I forgot that you just
have an eliminated thing right now I do
this freaking me right you make a bridge
yeah I'm surprised at how scared those
guys are considering he has a bow and
arrow
Oh God planned oh that guy is an x2 I
don't remember that you remember that oh
use my move later
oh right you have it don't you know but
I have to now select it yeah yeah look
at that five two damage
give them the business keep pressing it
oh you flew away now you're stuck
because that would combo that with the
wolves and it'd be a fun time how do you
get your armor in new game+ I mean for
us oh you gotta want the explosion you a
caught of war chest or shoulders
shoulders or is it the chest I can't
remember I think it was the chest
because it was the most expensive yeah
we had all our stuff to begin with so
I'm not really sure why if you're
missing something yeah oh there's three
new armor sets if we're not mistaken
three that's good that means there could
be a runic set yeah that'll excite now
your stuff Oh excited now I'm all in
today
I'm gonna tell my fiance I have a date
with God of War I'm sorry she could be
watching I could be in the doghouse
after this hmm not really it'll be fine
he should be able to shoot that guy
right I thought she gave him the power
yeah send the bird that's it I don't
know man maybe not
that's weird I honestly can't remember
you got to be able to write there's an O
okay that makes sense
try dropping that general try dropping
that him NIT Dewey
if we cut enough away the bridge above
us should reappear oh there goes
resistance mr. Santa it could be a
missus what's next Oh
I don't think it's necessarily based off
of this Dark Souls I mean like I get the
parallel New Game+ being a thing to
compare it to you because of Dark Souls
but that work yeah oh there's another
one
come here we got a present did not work
up now you can't see Oh John seen it you
got hit by that one attack oh boy
hey you get it back when she rubbish the
stream with the light okay got it thanks
for us pretty sure there's no new attack
and you ruin it attacks though sure yeah
but maybe I'm wrong and we'll find out
where is this a-hole
oh you got two stones you can step on
potentially nice headshot Oh what's up
dude oh this should work I'm here come
get me what are you waiting for come on
come on
and it's like Duke Duke he walks around
like stare off contest here he's not
gonna sleep at night he's a he's a
ranger Boy Ranger now you got to unlock
all that stuff again John like you've
pretty much all the water's still up
basically you gotta go through the
stories still the same oh here we go big
man little elemental how do you kill
something made of rock that's a good
question boy with skill
I dare ya
whoops
gotta be quick with those cuz they they
will explode on you oh that works right
yeah you see they explode eventually
yeah you snooze you lose
and dude does the blades affect the
story any point no it doesn't just know
that you have everything but the story
and all that stuff is pretty much the
same like from what we can tell so far
so give us those can't you still hit on
Wayne
yo yeah not oh oh oh yeah yeah it still
does some oh great shine come over here
guys they're not gonna Oh see ya see ya
I did like three-quarters hold yeah it
was pretty good you're getting icicles
right now yeah I'll try you gotta move
here got him yeah Adam
oh he baited you in oh wow yeah what's
up oh yeah you got to do something
sure do Marton heart late treasure let's
see what you got whatcha get move got
ancient heart I was hoping that was oh
that's what it wasn't ancient sir yeah
Oh pretty common stuff hopefully some
slag here or scag sucks the slag with
the hashtag slammer remember deputies I
keep calling the wrong thing
SCAP slag okay I only have 10 we need 10
more and we're not getting that anytime
soon
yeah how did he know to be so smart
yes Mraz I should because Rob started
with like 170,000 there's something
crazy like that thinking about calling
it soon yeah I think we're good all
right I just want to say thank you
everyone for tuning in to new game plus
mode now available forgot a war I think
caveats are probably that you beat it
and then you actually update but thanks
Rob for playing of course yeah yeah
thank you guys for watching fun time to
get back into I'm definitely gonna get
back into it yeah should be should be
cool so check it out if you want to stay
tuned the game spot of course for more
god of war coverage well I'm sure we'll
be doing some stuff with the new game
plus as we can Gamescom is this week -
big week of you know more news coming
out all right we're out we'll have some
more stuff throughout the week I know
our UK teams down at Gamescom so hmm
I'll be checking out a bunch of stuff
gets my alive of course we'll be back
tomorrow at 11:30 slightly later than
normal just because that was the time we
scheduled or Monster Hunters generation
stream we have a special guest coming in
tomorrow so we'll see you then hopefully
and then the rest of the week of course
11:00 a.m. Pacific thank you so much and
don't forget gray poppers at 2:00 p.m.
on Thursday what do you normos remote
yeah you survived although so far the
longest time we the longest run yeah we
put murmur death in every game so if you
dine again you move on to the next so
you got a warm excel list huh I think it
might be good [ __ ] I think it shouldn't
[ __ ] I'll give me give me a challenge I
don't know I think give me got a war
would be a little much but it wouldn't
be that long so I'm saying maybe that's
some your guys's skill short but even
for me I couldn't get past the first
part the first fight dude yeah and then
I was like no I'm good but yeah check it
out you get plus mode available god of
war and yeah thanks everyone for tuning
in and hit that sub button if you
haven't just so you guys get informed
for the future until then as Rob is
doing now seal it peace out bye bye
[Music]